[Musique]
bonjour salim lamrani merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin dans
la matinale de rtl france alors la
prison de guantanamo avait donc été créé
par george deubeuliou bouge dans le
sillage d'un des attentats du 11
septembre rappelez-nous quel était son
objectif pour accueillir qui
bonjour à vous merci de votre habitation
elle a été créée en 2002 cette prison de
guantanamo et elle constitue comme vous
le savez un affront aux fondements mêmes
de l'état de démocratie puisque c'est
une prison qui accueille des personnes
des des combattants ennemis qui sont
avérées ou supposées qui ne dispose
d'aucune existence légale qui ne dispose
d'aucune protection juridique et qui
n'ont pas accès à ce que tout citoyen
devrait avoir droit c'est-à-dire un
procès équitable et le respect de leur
intégrité physique et psychique c'est
devenu au fil du temps ça veut dire que
depuis le début ni le droit américain
ni le droit international ne s'y
applique
il faut rappeler que la base navale de
guantanamo est une base qui se trouve à
cuba et qui est
illégal et illégitime aux yeux du droit
international puisqu'elle se fait contre
la volonté souveraine du peuple de cuba
c'est une base qui a plus de 100 ans
d'existence et depuis 1959 c'est
l'avènement de la révolution cubaine les
autorités du pays exige la restitution
de ce territoire qui est occupée par la
france en barres et au début du 21e
siècle cette base a été peu devenu la
honte de l'humanité puisqu'elle a été
transformée en prison à ciel ouvert et
surtout en centre international de
torture alors on la torture on va y
revenir mais barack obama avait promis
de fermer guantanamo
joe biden lui aussi s'y est engagé
pourquoi ils ne le font pas rapidement
aux faux
à mon sens c'est qu'il n'arrive pas
trouvé de solution pour les détenus qui
se trouvent encore sur le territoire
cubain donc ils ne savent pas quoi faire
ce qu'il faut les rattraper les
rapatriés aux états unis est ce qu'il
faut les libérer et c'est la raison pour
laquelle cette base est toujours ouverte
et surtout ce sens de détention reste
toujours d'actualité un lieu vous lisiez
où il ya de fortes suspicions de torture
20 torture avait rien
effectivement il ya plus de doute à ce
sujet ça a été amplement documenté et ça
remet un peu en cause le la rhétorique
diplomatique des états unis qui
dissertent souvent sur la situation des
droits de l'homme à cuba mais lorsque
l'on est au fait de ces réalités on se
rend compte que washington ne dispose
pas de légitimité morale pour disserter
sur ces questions quand l'on sait que
l'endroit où l'on commet les pires
méfaits
concernant les droits de l'homme ces
gouvernements et les profils de ces
détenus qui étaient amenés à à
guantanamo il y avait des suspicions ou
alors c'étaient des terroristes avérés
qu'est ce qu'on en sait
alors je n'ai pas d'éléments factuels à
ce sujet mais ce que ce que je sais
c'est ce que j'aime dans la presse il ya
eu sûrement des combattants ennemis
avérés mais il ya eu également des gens
qui était totalement innocent d'ailleurs
il a eu un film récemment
qui est sorti au sujet d'un détenu joué
par le let l'acteur français tahar rahim
si ma mémoire est bonne huan innocent a
été incarcéré pendant des années là-bas
torturé pendant des années là bas parce
qu'il a été confondue avec une autre
personne selon vous est-ce qu'un
guantanamo illustre l'échec de la guerre
contre le terrorisme des américains
je crois qu'elle illustre le fait
d'appréhender les relations
internationales à travers le prisme de
la guerre les différents ne peuvent se
résoudre que par la voie pacifique la
voie diplomatique
le respect des principes fondamentaux du
droit international à savoir la légalité
souveraine entre les étals la
réciprocité dans les rapports avec les
autres pays et la non-ingérence dans
les affaires internes de notre nation
des autres nations il n'y a aucune
solution violente ou au belliqueuse à la
question du terrorisme international
alors qu'on le disait khalid cheikh
mohammed considéré comme l'un des
cerveaux des attentats du 11-septembre
devrait être entendu aujourd'hui par la
justice américaine comment comprendre
que vingt ans après il ne soit toujours
pas condamné qu'il n'y a pas eu de
procès et qu'ils croupissent toujours à
guantanamo
7 les etats-unis ont fait le choix
d'ignorer les principes fondamentaux de
l'état de droit parce que quel que soit
les méfaits commis par cette personne
elle a droit comme tout suspect à un
jugement équitable un procès à décharge
clairement énoncé et à la défense du
coût 39 encore personnes incarcérées
aujourd'hui à guantanamo aujourd'hui
quel avenir pour eux
c'est une question qu'il faudra sans
doute posé à l'administration maiden et
il est difficile d'apporter une réponse
claire à ce sujet ce que ce que réclame
la logique et le bon sens c'est que ce
centre de détention et de torture soit
définitivement fermée et que cette base
navale qui n'a plus lieu d'être
aujourd'hui soit restitué au peuple
souverain de cuba et pourquoi ils ne
peuvent pas être jugés et emprisonnés
sur le sol américain
mais ça c'est une bonne question parce
qu'il faudrait leur accorder je crois à
la reconnaissance de prisonnier de
guerre et j'ai cru comprendre que
l'administration les différentes
administrations étasuniennes ne
souhaitait pas leur accorder de
l'égalité juridique même si cela change
un peu merci beaucoup salim lamrani
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france je le rappelle vous
êtes maître de conférences hdr à
l'université de la réunion et
spécialiste des relations entre cuba et
les etats unis
merci
[Musique]